on sait que les québécois et québécoises
une bulle acheter le pétrole du canada
c'est mieux d'acheter de pétrole à
hauteur de saskatoon de de l'arabie
saoudite d'où vient le pétrole consommé
au québec actuellement 94 % du pétrole
brut
présent au québec y est soit du canada
soit des états unis le reste provient de
l'algérie l'arabie saoudite ne fournit
plus québec en pétrole depuis déjà 2006
cela dit les choses ont beaucoup changé
ces dernières années en 2012 par exemple
le pétrole au québec étaient achetés en
algérie au kazakhstan en angola ou
encore en norvège et moins de 10 % du
brut provenant de l'amérique du nord
tout a changé en 2015 notamment avec les
modifications apportées à l'oléoduc 9
bainbridges dire facilité transport du
pétrole provenant de l'ouest canadien et
des états unis
il y a une seule province canadienne qui
importe du pétrole saoudien
il s'agit du nouveau bredouille